I mean this is like Tuesday redux all
over again for me Krishna what do you
make of this kind of day well you know
it's the same worries it's China slowing
down and it's the Fed which insists on
tight it tightening despite the fact
that the world economy is headed lower
rather than higher it's the same set of
issues you know I think we reacted
positively to Dudley saying all sorts of
soothing words over the weekend Stanley
Fischer said all sorts of harsh words
and we have been reacting badly at the
end of the day it's really about growth
growth is slowing down and we'll just
have to slog through all of this so how
much more legs is this kind of sell-off
habit we spill over from august well you
know for the market to take one
direction i think we need to have one or
two things happen either the growth
outlook has to improve materially which
i think is unlikely or the Fed has to
say they're not going to do anything
last week that kind of put a start to
the sell-off right now the Fed probably
doesn't have anything to say for for a
bit until the 17th but maybe the
employment report may provide a bit of a
stop and Oliver Renick joins us now for
Bloomberg News and Oliver we have seen
those tried to start to lower their
calls for the SP Adam Parker the latest
today lowering it to 2200 from 20 to 75
but still not dramatic shifts in the in
that judgment no you're really not I
mean of 21 people that we serve a
strategist across the street 17 of them
are still still have have the same
estimates that they've had it pretty
much towards the beginning of the year
and the other thing to point out we
talked about earlier is that Adam and
the other folks that have brought down
their estimates they're not bringing
them down by a huge amount you know
apart from Sean dog from Jeffries saying
the ESPYs gonna in lower and I use lower
carefully as his price target is at 19
right now we're getting down there you
know these are these are largely moves
saying okay we're going to pull back a
little bit but overall the average is
still around 2200 which is a which is a
huge move up from here relative to you
know already but that's a 14-percent
rallies yeah it's no it's no small feat
for for stocks it obviously got a ways
to go especially if you know that
September rate hike is now kind of back
on the table I see you back on the table
kind of hesitantly because a week ago it
wasn't and now suddenly people are
talking about it again so does seem like
there's a few hurdles were going to get
over to get there o Krishna how much
repricing do you think the stock market
has to do when it comes to oil price it
seems like that has really been in part
leading the market and energy stocks
much lower i think the oil price thing
you know clearly it can take the market
significantly lower but i think the
probability of that is probably small i
think oil prices have been declined for
almost almost a year the story here
isn't oil oil is reacting to China just
as much as the rest of the market so the
the central story is slowdown in China
and what if anything Fed does to remedy
that situation for the US economy